oui je me suis beaucoup amusé parce
qu'il y avait des candidats dingue et
puis il ya toujours découverte
d'artistes extraordinaire à des moments
de magie en dehors de moi suivi ce
jeunisme et là est la vraie magie tu as
des rencontres très importantes pour les
gens donc sa j'adore
la semaine dernière il ya une troupe de
40 personnes ouais qui s'appelle les ou
caro est exactement qui ont fait le
choix avec un mélange de danse de gym et
de voltige
ils sont tellement assuré que même david
ginola le présentateur a utilisé le
golden buzzer
regardez
ces normes
un lycée je te rappelle de quoi aussi
d'un tel brevet
merci incroyable talent oui gilles je
peux poser une question à ce point que
j'aime beaucoup sa luge il va ya eu là
moi si je t'aime mais quand tu te dis je
sème dans une phrase pour commencer ce
qu'ils peuvent sortir une saloperie la
sphère gilbert rozon osé de saison elle
prend pas pourquoi vous n'avez pas tout
simplement renoncé à ces simples parce
que moi j'ai moi j'étais candidat dans
cette émission il ya douze ans et quand
et les missions étaient annulés makarian
ne serait sans doute pas cette can est
donc et par respect pour les artistes
par respect aussi pour la production tu
as une équipe de 20 personnes qui
travaillent pendant un an à la
conception de l'émission et on a reçu
ces gens est aujourd'hui ses jambes
après les premières diffusions par
exemple il ya leur alone que j'adore
complète jusqu'au mois de février parce
que le spectacle marche super bien donc
c'est un apache des artistes sur la vie
sur sur le quotidien des gens
yamoo là aussi qui à paris en ce moment
fayard il ya plein de gens que ça aide
et donc on peut pas on ne peut pas que
tu es tu sais comme c'est difficile de
venir être les visions tu sais comme
c'est difficile d'avoir un temps de
promotion c'est très hâte de repartir
voilà la raison principale